- Let's wrap up with one
more (audience applauds)
story aimed at inspiring hope.
This is #WHAT I'M LIKING
(audience applauds)
I never wake up and have no clue what kind
of day it's going to be.
I don't have to worry for even a second,
thanks to Noodles, the Pug.
Maybe the most popular canine on TikTok.
Every morning, the 13 year old pug's owner
wakes him up to see if it's a bones
or no bones type of day.
Now, if noodle decides to
stand, it's a bones day.
Go ahead.
Take on the world.
If it's a no bone's day,
getting out of bed might
not be too good an idea.
(audience laughs)
But let's check out one
of Noodles' daily updates.
Take a look.
- Good morning, everyone, and welcome back
to yet another round of no bones.
The game where we find
out if my 13 year old pug
woke up with bones.
And, in addition, we find out
what kind of day we're going to have.
Now, I think it's pushing
it to think we'll get
a third bones day in a row.
( Jonathan laughs)
Sure enough, down he goes, okay.
(audience applauds)
All right.
We have Noodles, along
with his owner Jonathan
on the line, who watches
on NBC 4 New York.
(audience applauds)
- Jonathan, how are you?
How did all of this.
How did this all start?
- So, no bones all started in college
when my best friend introduced it to us.
If she had a long day or
didn't want to go out,
she would just kind of
collapse and say, "Oh my bones.
I don't have bones."
Oh my gosh, she doesn't have bones.
So, it was just a fun little game.
And then six years later,
I adopted this dog and
we realized very quickly
that he was a pro at this game as well.
If it was, you know, like
a 11 o'clock in the morning
and he hadn't go out yet,
you know, the tank is full, man.
You gotta go.
I would go and try and wake them up
and see if he was ready to go out.
I'd sit him up and he
would just flop down.
We learned very early on
that if Noodle didn't want to
wake up or go anywhere,
he was not gonna to do it.
- That's, that's an American dog.
Now you say a.
Now, you say a, now
you say a no bones day,
it doesn't necessarily mean
it's gonna be a bad day, right?
It's not always a bad day, right?
- Oh, no, not no bad days.
I definitely contributed
to that false narrative.
And I'm looking to change it now.
So a no bones day really just means
you've got to be kind to yourself.
You've got to implement some,
self-care take a bath, stay
in bed, wear sweat pants.
You know, no bones, got no bones.
- Right, right
Bones day is a day where
you've got to, you know,
you've got to go after that
goal of yours or, you know,
people feel ambitious or like
I've been putting this off and
today's the day to do it.
So it's taken on a life of its own.
And it's just incredible.
- Well, it's,
it's been an inspiration relevant
that you're done with your
book right now, thanks a lot.
That's not all Kelly.
She's a long partner, pilot, pat,
and the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clark celebrate those who
create fearlessly just like you.
So there'll be using their
friction or erasable pen to write
you a check for $1,000.
Oh my God, that's thrill, oh my god.
(audience cheering)